but anxiety did you suffer anxiety your
whole life i don't say suffer
not anymore are you on medications for
it
i'm not um i uh well not even
not about my point is is that i
i do believe in the power
of love self-fulfilling prophecies
so if i say to myself like i'm suffering
from depression i'm suffering from
anxiety i'm suffering from this
then i'm the victim and i can't do
anything about it if i say to myself hey
all if i said myself this man for those
two weeks
in quarantine i suffered from anxiety i
i had a i have a garmin on my arm and it
tracks your steps i'd have 20 000 steps
someday in a three-bedroom apartment
and i don't say suffer i [ __ ] hate
that word
um and here's my favorite saying pain is
mandatory
suffering is optional so you will deal
with pain
pain is is universal there's not a human
being on the planet whether they're born
a
billionaire or born you know in
in the uh you know in a terrible
terrible situation pain is going to
happen
you've dealt with pain you will deal
with pain i've dealt with pain i will
deal with pain it's my choice whether or
not to accept it
and try and deal with it or to allow it
to make me suffer
so suffering is my option so i don't
suffer from anxiety i've dealt with
anxiety
i have a relationship with anxiety but
these days i
i see it as a school bully and i deal
with it i love that
i love it jared i think it's it's so
important because i remember my
psychologist said yeah hey anxiety could
be here
anxiety's in the back seat right now
i've said this before says the backseat
but you're driving
so you could know it's there and you go
hey what's up now [ __ ] you i'm driving
right now
i know you're there but you don't you
don't get to drive this car
i feel like there's a podcast i listen
to or something where somebody's talking
about death in the same
way and how they were terrified and
mortified of death and their mortality
and the fact that
oh my god i'm not gonna be able to wake
up one day or
go for a walk and they were like and now
they've become
uh a welcome friend like they're in the
passenger seat
and they'll say things and they're that
friend that you disagree with but you
love them
and you're like hey you know death is
telling you like hey this is all gonna
end
this could be the last time you take a
right at a stop sign hey this could be
the last time you have a diet coke
maybe a piece of rib gets caught in your
throat and you either believe that
person
and i've met a lot of people who have
had some pretty severe
who have dealt with not suffered who
have dealt with pretty severe
anxiety and depression and suicidal
thoughts
and i guess hold
he's like i heard koda was on the
podcast
well irv is also 90 deaf so the
neighbors probably think i'm screaming
at him and go
get over here but i can't hear i'm not
yelling at him
go ahead he's hearing the whisper but i
guess i just try when people are really
dealing with it
in a big big way there's some
that i've used in my own life this isn't
me like proselytizing like well if you
take this pill or practice this mantra
but i have found that accepting that
it's part of my life
makes it welcome like if i wake up and i
don't feel anxiety these days
i'm like what's wrong like what am i not
aware of you know honestly obviously
it's smart it's taking a lot of money a
lot of professional help a lot many many
years
but these days and not that i don't
falter not that i don't sometimes
just give my room and cry or something
but uh
by and large i remind myself so i
watched genevieve go through natural
childbirth
twice she said i do it three times we
had some issues with our eight-year-old
his quarters around his neck twice it
was kinked and
we ended up going to hospital then but
then i watched her two times
give natural childbirth you know no
advil and she
had she didn't say those exact words but
i got that she was like
you know when they would when when there
would be contractions
she would sit there and breathe through
it she's a [ __ ] dog boss man
but she would breathe through it and
ultimately after the fact she was sort
of like you know i know it's gonna hurt
i know it's gonna go away
and there's a great it's not roomy it's
reiki maybe there's a great quote
about something um you know deal with
the highs deal with the lows
i'm bastardizing but no feeling is final
um so accepting that accepting there
will be pain
like that's part of life life can suck
for all of us
and like can be amazing for all of us if
we choose to focus on that
but dealing with like you know no
feeling is final
this is painful you don't have to suffer